okay yeah so let me talk about this
topic this is a very simple observation
and motivating explaining some questions
I have now so let me talk about this so
okay so so the principal question is
whether we have forgiven a program
whether we have a sub linear space
algorithm by which I mean that the point
O Meal Time and m2 divided by 1 minus 1
1 minus epsilon space complexity and
then typically let's consider in this
talk st connectivity okay so okay so
what my question is what is the essence
of this hardness of this problem okay so
SD connectivity is a given directed
graph and smt and determine whether
there is a path from s to T okay and the
main parameter is n and m and then what
is known here is that this is NL and
then we we can solve this log this space
and then this time ok and then this is a
NL complete and then and then ok so this
is best known result so far I think
point O Meal Time and then this could be
called the sub linear but what I means x
sub linear anti-development zips alone
okay so this question has been open for
many years I think and then I would like
to ask what is the essence of this
hardness and well I well let's forget
about this parameter m well there may be
several reasoning for this but the main
reasoning I can say is that well we have
a this algorithm the linear space
algorithm and then we don't need care so
much about need to care this in this
talk I'm sorry oh I switched off
gee I'm sorry okay I should have put
this one wow so so it is since we are
talking about for no Meah time well we
don't need to worry about this and then
me okay before starting this uh this it
is it what oh okay good oh I'm sorry so
so we don't need to worry about this and
then maybe you might ask a specification
in this situation we removing edges but
this is a transitive reduction so it's a
more almost the same difficulty SSD
connectivity but maybe we should
constantly be more in this context of
the sub linear computability some seven
linear space computability but anyway
let's forget about this m for a while
okay in this talk okay so so my priest
of question is this and then and then
for discussing the essence of this
hardness we may consider some variant of
st connectivity and then of course
undirected graph this can be solved in
the log space which is born on your time
and then recently we had some result on
the planar st connectivity in the case
of the planar graph we have this square
root of n upper bound so in order to
discuss the essence maybe we had better
consider some other program and then
today i would like to mention that the
undirected st connectivity with a
bounded length would be a some
appropriate candidate okay for this
particular one okay so what is this so
we are given undirected graph and then
SNT and then bound d and then determine
whether there is a path of length at
most D using a d edges okay so so
formally speaking this is the definition
and then so okay this is a functional
version so we can ask to compute this
function okay and so well in the log
space computation this is equivalent to
the standard SD connectivity and then
but our question is what if we have this
some saving of epsilon can we get a
similar saving okay right also so this
is a reduction usually if we consider
reduction so this is a standard
reduction from SD connectivity to the
unbounded undirected st connectivity we
make a copy of graph n times okay and
then of course this is connected but if
you ask the the lengths and shortest
paths form from s to t then this is
equivalent right so the director des the
connectivity equivalent to this but
unfortunately the number of vertices
becomes n square so if we have a saving
epsilon then we would have a saving of
this type and then so if shown is larger
than half then we have some sub linear
space algorithm but this may not be good
enough okay so if we consider the
reduction we would need saving to the
lodges and half but if you can use this
algorithm recursively with the depth are
then we would have something like this
for the saving formula and then so if R
is larger than affront to the inverse of
Egyptian then we would have some long
linear space algorithm but the
polynomial depends on our but by simple
algorithmic technique trick we can get
this kind of result and so the saving is
almost the same depending on our again
the time is polynomial to do ok so the
ticket trick is very simple we use the
separator kind of separator okay in the
case of planar graph we use the
separator actually in the case of planar
graph we have a square root of size
separator this is the why we got this
sorry this is why we got this result
okay for the planar standard separator
we have this result and then if you can
make the psycho separator we could
improved in this way okay and then in
this case we consider we use that the
this kind of separator that is used in
the old paper and then this is the the
set VK DK is the set of vertices whose
length from starting point starting
vertex is K Modell so we divide the set
of vertices into the L pot okay and then
keep one of them as a separator so at
least except for the special case
everything is within a distance L we
have some k such that v k has smaller
number elements so we can keep these
elements to recall the reach ability and
then within this support we can use this
bounded lengths argues me that we are
assuming and then in this way we could
get this result ok so this saving would
gives us a similar saving ok so this is
the very simple observation and then the
thing I would like to ask is whether
this is very core program for NL for
example and then maybe this is not true
i'm not so sure about this but let's
look at this problem instead of the
reach ability we ask for the distance ok
and so we are given that directed graph
and then also cost function and then ask
determine whether there is a short path
from s to t whose total cost is a lesson
w ok so i don't know how to use that
previous algorithm for for for showing a
good non sublinear computability but we
can still modify their algorithm to get
this similar result and then by using
this technique we can get a similar
argument to show that well
version of this program is again the
sort of hard for this problem okay but
I'm not so sure whether this is the real
cord for the NL program maybe what so
what my question is what will be
appropriate question we should focus for
this Sabrina Sabrina space compatibility
and maybe this is almost same as
actually essentially the same as
iterated matrix multiplication under the
mean and plus okay so if we consider
this then maybe we would like to
consider sharp air or something like
that because we are talking about more
than log space sub linear space and
polynomial time maybe we can look at the
more higher class so this is a P
complete problem and this is Chappelle
okay so this is what I would like to ask
today thank you
I one more point okay please consider
coming to Tokyo next year and deadline
of submission is mid-november I think
complex this every conference
advertisements from our sponsors and
looking at other after classes yeah I
was wondering if or essay C 1 log CFO
would be interesting because it suggests
is in my so this is a essential across
where it's a good versions of the
problem yes yes yes yeah yes yeah
let's go the speakers